la proposition de loi sur les lanceurs
d'alert sera débattu au sénat les
députés avaient adopté à l'unanimité ce
projet protecteur en novembre dernier
mais les sénateurs ont tenté d'en vider
le contenu à tel point que la presse a
dénoncé un retour en arrière un texte en
charpie un collectif de lanceurs d'alert
de nombreuses ong et des syndicats
protestent avec une tribune dans les
échos il s'insurge alors qu'elle vient
de prendre la présidence de l'union
européenne la france qui s'était dotée
avec la loi sapin de d'une des quatre et
législations les plus avancés au monde
risque de devenir la lanterne rouge de
l'europe nous appelons solennellement
les sénateurs à rétablir à minima le
texte de l'assemblée nationale et à se
saisir pleinement des propositions de
notre coalition afin de clarifier et
renforcer notre dispositif de protection
des lanceurs d'alerté la proposition de
loi portée par le député centriste
sylvain vazey herman venait améliorer
les dispositions de la loi sapin de en
2016 elle prévoyait d'asseoir le statut
des lanceurs d'alerté et un mode de
signalements adapté elle mettait en
place un soutien financier si la partie
adverse a signé le lanceur d'alerté en
justice elle lui supprimer ses revenus
un second texte faisait du défenseur des
droits l'interlocuteur privilégié de ces
vigies de la société sylvain vazey arman
avait même imaginé que la france
deviendrait le fer de lance de la
protection des lanceurs d'alert mai en
commission les sénateurs ont sabordé
plusieurs dispositions pivot du texte au
point que les personnes travaillant sur
les dossiers de lanceurs d'alert on
parler de régression de violation des
exigences de la directive européenne de
2000 19 que cette proposition de loi
devait transposer quels ont été les
modifications opérées par les sénateurs
elle porte sur la définition même du
lanceur d' alerte les sénateurs ont
supprimé la notion de dénonciation de
menaces ou préjudice pour l'intérêt
général remplacée par celle d' acte ou
deux missions allant à l'encontre des
objectifs poursuivis par les règles de
droit cela a l'air très technique voire
anodin mais en réalité cela ça
complètement les principes d'éthique du
lanceur d alerte car le droit n'est pas
toujours enfreint lorsqu'une société la
sciemment l'intérêt général par exemple
on ne pourrait plus considéré comme un
lanceur d'alert celui qui dénonceraient
un dossier de production d'un médicament
autorisé mais dangereux comme le
médiateur à l'époque où un problème de
santé pas encore identifiés comme des
cancers environnementaux
les sénateurs refusent aussi d'accorder
la une protection à certaines aides des
lanceurs d'alert comme les associations
non agréé qui sont pourtant parfois très
utile ou bien renseignés pour révéler
des scandales les sénateurs ont aussi
sévi en souhaitant que le lanceur
d'alert révèle ces informations en
premier à sa direction avant d'en
référer au public alors que c'est bien
sûr le plus souvent impossible
et puis ils ont décidé que les lanceurs
d'alert pourraient être poursuivis en
cas d'atteinte à la vie privée ou d'
atteinte aux systèmes de traitement
automatisé de données tout cela bien
considérer revient à dire que par
exemple antoine deltour le comptable qui
avait permis la révélation du scandale
d'évasion fiscale des look slicks irène
frachon qui avait dénoncé les effets du
médiator n'aurait pas pu bénéficier du
statut de lanceurs d'alert ses diverses
réécriture pourrait très bien en
revanche servir la cause des lobbys une
enquête de mediapart avait révélé par
exemple que l'association bretonne des
entreprises agroalimentaires avait écrit
à certains sénateurs pour suggérer des
amendements à l'armée la défenseure des
droits claire hédon a appelé les
sénateurs à maintenir toutes les
avancées de la proposition de loi sur
les lanceurs d'alert voté par les
députés en première lecture les lobbys
vont-ils réussir à se tailler la part du
lion si certains des amendements restent
en place la directive européenne de 2000
19 impose aux lois nationales de ne pas
être en recul même si l'assemblée
nationale aura le dernier mot
l'offensive des sénateurs est un très
mauvais signal pour ceux qui ont
sacrifié leur carrière et parfois leur
vie privée au service de l'intérêt
général
la maison des lanceurs d'alert appelés à
se rassembler mercredi matin devant le
sénat